[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons débattre de l'actualité
essayer de l'éclairer et pour le faire
nous sommes avec jean baptiste duclair
bonjour patrice où nous enseigne à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en charge d'un bezina on chauffe
vous enseignez à roye tout vous êtes
tous les deux spécialistes de droit
public de droit constitutionnel et on va
parler beaucoup de réformes
constitutionnelles qui est un sujet qui
on chante positivement jonction de la
jolie lyonnaise est rien publier encore
c'est le rêve non non mais j'ai
également vu l'intérêt que ça me suicide
j'en vois si m il peut être l'éditeur de
maurice duverger mais vous revenez du
vous étiez à l'inauguration du salon du
livre la soirée inaugurale avec le
président de maquereaux et sa femme et
sa famille sa femme alors c'était
fascinant fascinant c'est pas tout à
fait en rapport avec la littérature mais
mais franchement moi je vous me
connaissez j'aime beaucoup de présidents
macron choquer tout ce qu'il fait est
très bien pour l'instant enfin sa femme
n'avait rien que d'être obligé mais non
mais hier jeudi on avait l'impression
que c'était obama trump et poutine
ensemble et qu'il fallait 450 gardes du
corps pour protéger brigitte mcneill
mais c'était affolant
j'ai jamais vu un tel déploiement de
policiers de garde du corps de trucs
double cordon de sécurité pour qu'elles
aillent regarder un bouquin au stand de
la bible
bibliothèque nationale de france je veux
dire c'est aberrant comme déchaînement
de là on est vraiment dans une espèce de
2 à cette adresse ici c'est tout on n'a
jamais vu une promesse non non on n'a
jamais vu une première dame protégé
comme ça julia shaw ou alors c'est
passer pour pas qu'elle tombe je sais
pas mais il n'y a pas de ces sites est
ridicule
il y avait une phrase formidable c'est
dans paris match je crois qu'il
racontait le voyage en inde
et il ya cette phrase même les chèvres
l'asa lui même les écrans d'ordinateurs
se prosterner et donc et alors outre la
visite présidentielle
alors il y aura d'ailleurs un discours
lundi
du président macron devant l'académie
française sur le sur la francophonie
c'est la langue française c'est un beau
salon ben saleh à s'avère tout à fait
tout à fait intéressant il ya toujours
des gens qui critiquent un peu le salon
qui est un petit peu plus réduit que
qu'il ya une quinzaine d'années puisque
il ya un ou deux gros éditeurs qui
boudent le salarié voilà mais sinon les
nécessaires pour un éditeur
ah oui je pense que c'est impossible à
rentabiliser enfin les fans très
difficile mais c'est un truc d'image de
crédibilité et c'est quand même très
très bien parce que tous les gens tous
les acteurs du livre qui habitent en
dehors de paris qui peuvent venir la
pente pendant le week-end et on voit les
principaux auteurs les principaux
éditeurs les principaux stands etc
donc c'est comme pour tous tous les
bibliothécaires tous les libraires tous
les gens qui aiment donner un
rendez-vous incontournable
donc ça c'est très rapide et il ya un
stand des éditions là je dis absolument
absolument ça c'est très agréable c'est
très sympa et puis alors d'être dernier
point mais ça c'est on tombe dans la
géopolitique et je pense que poutine
doit trembler sur ses bases
parce que la réaction française à
l'assassinât de l'espion h un c2d
d'éviter le stand de la russie que
pourtant l'invité d'honneur du salon
quand même est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est la main de poutine dairy milk
oui mais en même temps c'est un petit
peu un raisonnement boules parce qu'on
peut dire comme il sait qu'il est qu on
va dire qu'il est trop intelligent pour
le faire il peut donc le faire à la
radio days ya ça mais moi je suis assez
d'accord avec le ce qu'avait dit le la
première ministre
anglaise soit 6 soit c'est poutine soit
ils se sont fait vous c'est pas lui
directement ils sont fait voler le
produit c'est encore pire
on peut être vraiment inquiété
et c'est pas grave c'est une crise avec
avec le renvoi des diplomates très
importante quand même je pense quand
même pour accuser aussi frontalement
foot five je pense que au niveau des
services de renseignement ils doivent
posséder des informations qu'on possède
pas parce que prendre le risque d'une
telle crise et de voir tous les alliés
la france l'allemagne qui s'associent et
l'angleterre pour prendre position avec
poutine avec tous les risques que cela
peut engendrer sur la scène diplomatique
alors qu'il ya des dossiers brûlants au
proche orient
mon avis je pense que un clocher de
l'église
on a renvoyé comme ça quelques quelques
diplomates mais les risques qui sont à
la city sont riches aux pauvres donc les
frais sanctions n'ont pas été il aurait
dans quinze jours les diplomates vont
venir y avait déjà eu une crise renvoyé
à l'époque à cause des écoutes une
cinquantaine de diplomates russes du
temps de mitterrand dans l'actualité
qu'on va le bélier a programmé n'oublie
apprend ça rattrape un peu plus sur la
réforme institutionnelle sur balles à
faire johnny pourquoi ça nous passionne
et puis sur la sphère compta est-ce que
quand on a fait la peine de prison à
laquelle on a été condamné on doit
encore payer ou est ce que on voit là
des libres de faire ce qu'on veut quand
même un événement d'actualité c'est pour
la première fois il ya des élections
partielles à mayotte et marine le pen
qui a tenu
le congrès du front national la semaine
dernière se prononce pour le candidat
républicain
donc non est ce que c'est une frontière
une question chi barrière qui est élevé
bon c'est pas plus grave que quand les
communistes se déclarer pour les
socialistes ce que j'ai après voilà
c'est genre il y avait une alliance il
va nommer un avant avant lui arrive
quelque chose de théorie des ans après
la droite a refusé ce qu'on attend du
bas et ils ont très bien fait qu'après
heureusement des gens ne sont pas
propriétaires de leurs électeurs donc
sinon ça veut dire qu'il peut être une
nouvelle stratégie du front national
n'en vendent du rassemblement national
puisque cet acte l'âge chez reçu un peu
d'accord avec toi jean charles est pas
significatif de quelque chose de
particulier dans le sens où quand on
quand on apporte son soutien à un
candidat ou un autre c'est plus une
démarche par défaut c'est parce que
notamment bon voilà c'est une offre
politique mais c'est vrai que ça
s'inscrit dans un climat qui nous
intéresse particulièrement parce que on
a affaire un laurent wauquiez qui est en
train de flirter un petit peu avec les
limites et que justement on n'a jamais
été en dix ans en disant voilà il faut
dire disons aussi il y aura jamais
d'accord les orages si c'est plus vidéo
logiquement c'est plus sur le plan
d'asile et que ces derniers temps on est
tous à protéger plutôt à pomper les voix
du front national
l'idée chère qu'un rapprochement
idéologique pour toi là l'idée c'est à
mon avis de radicaliser le discours au
niveau de la droite pour essayer de
droitiser pour se prétendre être une
force d'opposition ce qui n'est pas
forcément une intelligente comme
stratégie et ce qui du coup amène les
journalistes ou les observateurs
politiques à plus se questionner sur les
frontières qui peuvent continuer à
exister entre le front national et la
droite mais à mon sens le front national
a quand même une particularité
idéologique et une particularité même
notamment de ses soutiens et son
électorat qui font que quand bien même
marine le pen pourrait se rapprocher
d'un candidat
des élections partielles à mayotte ça
signifie pas nécessairement que est en
train d'ouvrir la main à l air est que l
air va lui-même tendre la main au front
national à mon sens c'est quand même
deux acteurs trop différents pour se
marier
demain mais ça laisse entendre quand
même c'est peut-être même aussi un petit
peu de séduction c'est à dire de se dire
voilà on s'est quand même bordeaux n'est
pas celle ci c'est une fiction partial
c'est mayotte avec la situation
particulière de mayotte aussi et puis ça
peut aller avec la dédiabolisation aussi
oui c'est à dire que c'est une manière
de dire que le front national n'est
finalement peut être pas si éloigné du
disque le rassemblement maintenant un ca
de rassemblement national
exactement qui se rassemblera avec qui
ces questions parce que marine le pen
sait plus quoi faire pour essayer de
récupérer un peu l'oeil à sa nièce qui
est qu'il attend au coin du bois et
qu'un fusil son père qui continue lui
taper dessus
philippot mais après au delà de tout ça
pour ne pas que ça occupe le fait que à
mayotte est beaucoup plus important que
la main tendue du front national c'est
quand même un truc quasiment insoluble
c'est un département français voilà qui
cac +2 d'étrangers que de quelques de
français parce que tout le monde arrive
là bas on va peut-être en parler après
le sujet passionnant de la révision
constitutionnelle mais il y avait une
idée de la valeur des ministres nommés
de la ministre qui disait on n'a qu'à
mettre l'hôpital en dans un système
extraterritoriale est comme ça d on
pourra accueillir tous les étrangers
tous les migrants qui viendront dont les
soignera maison
on assistera enfin on aidera aux
accouchements etc
mais les bébés nés sur le sur cette
clinique est un attrait évidemment parce
que c'est un département français dans
ces régions assez pauvre en réalité tous
les constitutionnalistes sont dit mais
c'est juste impossible un truc pareil au
moins d'en faire une ambassade et de
refiler le bébé aux états unis y aille
bah moi j'y vois moi j'y vois le signe
supplémentaire du déclin quand même du
front national parce que j'ai
l'impression que finalement c'était sa
dernière carte à jouer le front national
pour moi c'est l'idée d'un parti n'y ni
gauche ni droite qui joue la france
c'est un parti qui est contre l'ump s
est là finalement de se raccrocher à un
wagon parti de gouvernement et l'air je
crois que c'est pour le parti finalement
dangereux et je m'en félicite d'ailleurs
dangereux du point de vue de ses son
électorat dont on sait maintenant que le
front national n'est plus celui qu'il
était il ya bien longtemps c'est à dire
un parti très à droite le front national
a joué notamment sur les la terreur
prend doublé
vous pouvez y est le fait de se marquer
finalement dans le clivage pour moi va
précipiter
plus encore à mon avis son déclin et j'y
vois le signe d'une faiblesse au niveau
du chef au niveau du capitaine du navire
et donc je suis plutôt ravi de cette
décision
cbc pas aussi une façon de rebattre les
cartes parce que il ya quand même
tendance chez les républicains il y
avait des noms même pour un accord avec
avec le front national
une tendance sais pas s'il est pas
majoritaires mais enfin il est temps
elle est importante et donc c'est tout
comme le fait de tendre la main ça ça
peut changer quand même l'homme
justement je suis pas certaine que ce
soit complètement un affaiblissement
dans le sens où à mon avis marine le pen
laisse entendre que y'a du coût des
portes qui sont encore ouvertes qu'elle
n'a peut-être pas forcément exploiter
parce que encore une fois comme comme je
les geler plusieurs fois dit je pense
que cet acte politique est assez isolée
mais si elle donnait suite à cette vague
politique à mon sens justement c'est une
manière pour elle de dire qu' elle est
loin d'être morte
en tout cas le parti front national a
encore des cartes à jouer notamment par
rapport à cette frontière d'un discours
des daurades droite qui pourrait tout à
fait être séduits par les propositions
cas là je me souviens de la dernière
émission politique qu'est la fête où
elle laissait entendre que justement
elle était absolument contre aucune
proposition donc l'avenir nous
et puis nous infirmera le front national
a dit qu'il est en crise on verra on
verra quand tu auras des élections il
convient convoyer fraudes partout autant
que le fait la presse me semble-t-il
mais son problème s'il veut arriver un
jour au pouvoir c'est pas pouvoir passer
des allées on sait que jusqu'à présent
personne ne pouvait s'allier avec lui il
ya eu un peu du pontet nyon enfin c'est
quand même très léger pour faire une
majorité vous faire une majorité vous
pouvez pas le faire tout seul
donc c'est aussi peut-être ce changement
de stratégie cela c'est oui mais je
crois qu'il ya des parties même si c'est
encore une fois mayotte et même
situation particulière de meilleur mais
c'est un signe qui est donné on change
de nom du parti il ya cette première
proposition d'alliance je pense que ça
va se poursuivre mais je crois qu'il ya
des partis qui ne peuvent pas faire
alliance comme on dit parfois ya des
gens ne peuvent pas mettre en couple
c'est un des problèmes c'est ouais et
c'était vrai pour le parti communiste
français pour le rpr du général de
gaulle en raison de la logique qu'ils
défendent elle a changé alors oui c'est
vrai qu'il a fait avec le oui c'est vrai
que c'est la voirie c'est fini mais
justement je pense que c'était quelqu'un
qui l'est plus c'est quelqu'un qui voit
là mais justement je pense qu'il va
payer arrive au rôle officiel ce qui va
arriver pour le front national
précisément parce que ce sont des partis
qui peuvent pas s'allier parce qu'ils
ont leur fond de commerce est justement
le
un dépassement fête du livre du mode de
pensée traditionnelle avec une logique
bon qui est internationaliste pour le
parti communiste même si ça a évolué un
peu après rpf avec le général de gaulle
où on était dans le ni droite ni gauche
on étend d'un rassemblement national là
tout d'un coup ça liés à un parti de
droite
pour moi c'est complètement modifié
l'équilibré général du front national et
je pense que il faisait des scores
extrêmement important justement parce
qu'il avait cette logique je pense qu'il
avait atteint ces sommets
et là je pense que du coup ça va il
avait appuyé la stratégie du père le pen
qui était de rester dans l'opposition
mais c'est celui de carles 26 jean marie
villemin d'or c'est exactement c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que nous en
marine le pen je n'avais aucune envie de
qu'une envie d'aller leur vie d'harry
plus gros score ils étaient ravis
d'avoir un parti allemand qui n'arrêtait
pas de râler de laïcs ont testé etc
or marine le pen peut-être elle a vu un
petit peu de sa wii délimité mais en
même temps elle a elle a entrevu
peut-être une possibilité d'arriver à
quelque chose
sediba voilà il faut donc changer mais
peut-être que la vocation d'un parti de
partis comme le front national c'est
c'est de rester protestataires dans tout
ce qui est assez nombreux mais
uniquement dans la il ya en europe des
exemples
c'est justement ce genre de parti
communiste qui arrive à faire des
alliances c'est ce qui me semble un
petit peu difficile dans l'idée
d'annoncer la mort du front national
c'est que les prochaines échéances dont
on parle voix électorales sont sûrement
les échéances européennes et la
nationale pourrait nous surprendre
encore une fois parce que pour le coup
malheureusement ce ne sont pas des
partis isolé en europe
bien loin au contraire n'est qu'un
d'europe n'ont pas macron ça oui madame
aussi faire confiance y avoir ni au
président et au royaume uni
c'est nos missiles à six il arrive à
régler le problème vraiment être ce
qu'il esquive fait beaucoup d'attrait
profond nationale c'est notamment là qu
elle la question des religions de
l'islam etc ce cas ci le couple exécutif
gère bien les choses ça dégonflera très
vite que le front national
oui vous avez parlé d'un cran pour ça
justement bas il y avait peut-être y
voir un des premiers
obstacle difficile à surmonter pour le
pour le gouvernement c'est la grève à la
sncf
la réforme de la sncf femmes du statut
des cheminots et les grèves qui ont été
à nos sections des grèves un peu on dit
pas perdre les noms dans ce cas-là
m'enfin c'est des grèves deux fois deux
jours par semaine jours par semaine dans
36 jours de grève c'est totalement je
vous propose de regarder un sujet
justement sur la cgt et puis on reparle
après de cette nouvelle position des
syndicats
l'heure est au bilan de l'année 2010 est
pour la cgt des yvelines environ 150
délégués syndicaux ont échangé sur les
manifestations estivales contre les
ordonnances réformant le droit du
travail
des mobilisations qui n'ont pas touché
le projet du gouvernement
il ya eu des mobilisations
majoritairement soutenu par l'opinion
mais on n'a pas su encore à mener assez
de monde dans les mobilisations et c'est
ce qu'on travaille
voilà d'aller plus au contact des
salariés de rendre tous nos syndiqués
plus acteur de les informer sur les
grands enjeux les mobilisation était
importante
pas suffisamment encore pour faire
reculer le gouvernement
justement ce qui ce qu'il faut c'est
continuer à militer continuer à discuter
avec ses collègues de travail avec sa
famille avec ses amis pour pour faire
comprendre que toute cette situation
toutes ces attaques ne sont pas normales
ce 20ème congrès de la cgt des yvelines
l'occasion de préparer les prochaines
mobilisations à l'image du jeudi 22 mars
pour protester contre le projet de
réforme ferroviaire avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence ou la fin du statut de
cheminot pour les nouveaux embauchés
et puis le 22 et une convergence de
lutte des cheminots des fonctionnaires
de l'énergie des entretiens certaines
entreprises du privé donc c'est c'est
une étape où on va ensemble réfléchir
comment on donne des suites et comme on
élargit ce que je disais tout à l'heure
et donc il ya besoin que le 22 mars soit
puissant mais également aussi une
mobilisation des associations d'usagers
et de la population plus largement au
delà des cheminots parce que le rapport
spinetta et
est-ce qu'il reprit par le gouvernement
c'est une attaque purement et simplement
du service public ferroviaire
une autre journée de mobilisation est
déjà prévue ce jeudi 15 mars par les
retraités les salariés des ehpad et les
aides à domicile revient qu'à plusieurs
enjeux d'ailleurs avec ce sujet pour
pour les syndicats pour la société
notamment ils ont raté quand même la
mobilisation sur la loi travail et là
ils espèrent mobiliser sur la sncf sur
la réforme de la sncf avec cette grève
un peu étrange en dix ans la danse bien
à l'avancé comme ça vous allez vous ne
pourriez pour des baltringues jours de
grève mais je crois que maison les
usagers ont l'air dans le premier acte
fourbe avoir assez furieux d'ailleurs
d'abord quand on demande enfin partout
en france on demande aux gens de
travailler plus de faire des efforts et
c est là il annonce la fleur au fusil 36
jours de grève mais sait on est au delà
de ce qu'on peut imaginer dans la
perversion intellectuelle
rien ne justifie sable afin si ce n'est
de nous montrer que c'est les pierres
réac qui soit c'est à dire que rien ne
doit bouger et rien ne doit changer
il n'y a rien de dramatique les petites
lignes
c'était le seul truc que les français
auraient pu soutenir c'était l'abandon
des ben ali n'est pas dans le projet
exactement donc donc donc ça ne marche
pas sinon il n'y a rien de dramatique à
ce que les nouveaux entrants à la sncf
et un nouveau statut et qui ne soit pas
celui de l'enquêté une crainte d
des gens qui travaillent et la sncf ont
peut le comprendre je crois que ce qui
est important dans cet enjeu là c'est
finalement la répétition de ce type de
processus c'est que on se rend compte
qu'en france au moment où on veut
réformer
on a aussi une énorme capacité d'inertie
nos services publics ou n'est ce pas
forcément que le service public un
d'ailleurs cette idée de de faire des
grèves d'aller contester et c est
finalement c'est ce qui a pu alimenter
le on ne touche rien parce qu'en france
on est très attachés à nos prix village
et moi ce que j'ai peur c'est que ça ne
fasse qu'augmenter un petit peu la cote
d' emmanuel macron parce que lui son
grand cheval de bataille c'est moi je
serais le président qui fera tout
bougeait et au contraire je vais vous
démontrer que j'irai plus loin que ça de
la part de lumière feront donc à mon
avis au même titre que la loi travail il
va arriver à démontrer tout simplement
parce que à mon avis ça va s'effondrer
comme tout le reste
mais qu'est la crise et syndicats qui va
arriver à démontrer que voilà il faut
passer il peut passer donc on parlerait
même à mon avis de d'augmenter sa cote
de popularité est de montrer que c'est
un peu pitoyable d'en arriver à une
capacité d'inertie aussi aussi peu
idéologique finalement est aussi
systématique pour rien donc du coup ça
affaiblit à mon sens vraiment leur
disque en même temps enfin c'est là
contrairement à leur travail
il semble y avoir non possibles
rassemblements dès et syndicats oui
alors cette règle celle d'été
c'est en général c'est d'ailleurs ça qui
fait bouger les lignes
c'est à dire où il ya une véritable
force et ouais alors née en moi je crois
je me demande jusqu'à quel point le
soutien de la population est réel parce
que on a parlé l'exemple de 95 c'est
vrai que ici on avait pu comprendre le
combat social et c'est ce qui plaît
train car sylvain suckert de population
alors aux grèves et j'ai l'impression
que c'est peut-être un petit peu moins
le cas aujourd'hui
d'après les sondages c'est l'inversé
associe 70% des français qui sont qui
sont tous pour la réforme et qui
comprennent pas les motifs de la grève
on n'est plus dans une optique où les
français ont envie de soutenir ce
changement peut-être parce que justement
emmanuel macron est encore tout neuf
dans l'opinion et il je je je je suis
pas sûr que ce combat social même avec
un rassemblement des syndicats gagne là
la ferveur qu'il attend de son combat
surtout que ça s'annonce beaucoup plus
comme une réforme est que comme une
véritable réforme et c'est un peu la
méthode de mâcon ce qui est tout à fait
intelligent c'est à dire que en gros ils
défoncent pas la porte comme un bourrin
il entrouvre la porte il est un coin
dedans pourra jamais la refermer et
c'est bien donc l'idée de réforme va
avancer
mais mme effectivement j'ai quand on va
regarder offert à mesure jusqu'à ce
qu'on va de juin ce qui va se passer
pour la sncf c'est vraiment des
changements homéopathiques
mais il ya l'effort et les forêts fait
et on début de cette idée que c'est
peut-être possible de réformer
donc ça c'est très bien et puis enfin
moi ya quand même une chose qui me qui
m'intéresse c'est que 36 jours de grève
ça fait quasiment plus d'un mois de
salaire en moins est ce que vraiment
c'est jour de grève on a l'assurance
qu'ils ne seront pas payés aux grévistes
et est ce que tout le monde à tous les
grévistes qui ont signé pas là pour 36
jours de grève ils ont réalisé que il ya
des gens qui se battent pour avoir un
13e mois et eux ils se battent pour en
avoir onze quoi visiblement donc la
citation du jour ça sera emmanuel macron
ne défendent pas la porte comme à bourg
[Rires]
c'est ce qui me gêne un petit peu c'est
à dire que bon le droit de grève
je trouve que c'est un endroit important
qui figure d'ailleurs dans la
constitution c'est le préambule de la
constitution 1946 un droit de grève mais
c'est un droit
face à quel finalement on n'est pas tous
égaux puisqu'en fonction de la situation
qu'on occupe on peut lui donner une
répercussion plus ou moins importantes
donc évidemment si vous travaillez dans
le domaine des transports vous avez une
capacité de nuisance du genoa mordre
tentes et et qui fait que vous
travaillez vraiment public après c'est
un peu plus facile que dans le privé les
graves
oui c'est alors c'est alors oui mais je
commence à crier non parce que si on si
on continue dans le débat
constitutionnel mais je promets à
jean-charles d'elle tout à fait parce
que nous avons un deuxième principe est
celui de continuité des services publics
et qui imprime pour les grévistes et à
plus de grève
voilà dans le domaine public dans le
domaine privé parce que c'est plus
compliqué ça aussi mais je parlais pas
de juridique pour l'homme et d'ailleurs
ont créé des statuts différents par
exemple le droit de grève
quoique reconnu par la constitution est
interdit pour interdire oui à certaines
personnes magistrats minute et allez je
trouve d'ailleurs qu'on fait une
distinction trop brutale entre ceux qui
ne peuvent pas et ceux qui peuvent et je
crois que pour certaines personnes qui
justement une capacité de nuisance sur
le grand nombre sur la libre circulation
des personnes des travailleurs sur qui a
des répercussions sur leur situation
privée notamment sur le sur l'oeil sur
les salaires alors sans peut-être aller
jusqu'à interdire le droit de grève
à ceux qui
travaille dans le domaine des transports
je crois qu'il faudrait à tout le moins
créé d une forme de limitation pour
éviter justement qu'on puisse mettre les
gens en otage moi je suis toujours
surpris qu'on peut rendre grâce à
sarkozy puisque en fait c'est un service
minimum qui est prévu à savoir
l'obligation d'information n'implique
voilà de prévenir suffisamment à l
avance mais ça reste relativement
marginal voilà il veut le faire grève
ils ont indiqué raison du presque jamais
dans les deux virages de contourner en
tout cas c'est justement c'était une
manière de s'installer le régime
législatif du service minimal justement
je crois que c'est une c les contraintes
qui n'ont qui l'ont imposé deux jours
trois jours après on sait qu'après une
solution légende à la scène jours par
semaine après c'est pas ben attia je
peux pas prendre le transilien bon ben
je vais prendre un jet privé feria alors
je prends le bus je will à la fin visé
un bus selon laquelle est ce que vous
savez quel jour un mépris une
méconnaissance du tissu social et
économique de la france de la part des
gens qui disent ça te dire que oui j'ai
jean-baptiste ou à angers vous c'est pas
grave lundi mardi faisait cap aller
bosser puisse dire est que ces samedi et
dimanche ce thème ils sont fous à mon
avis l'idée c'est justement d'obtenir un
soutien idéologique de la part des
jeunes est malheureusement le pari est
perdu d'avancé vraiment pour ça qu'à mon
avis là qu'on verra on verra
voilà l'avenir nous le dira un jardin de
bezina justement vous parlez de cette
posture peut-être cette position du
président de la république de vouloir
réformer si on parle de réformes
institutions constitutionnelles
on en est là puisque
il ya une opposition du sénat on va en
voir un peu sérieux toutes les réformes
et voies sur lesquelles il ya une
opposition distincts mais on sent que
emmanuel macron serait prêt à aller
jusqu'au référendum si jamais ça bloque
au parlement peut-être parlons d'abord
des différents champs
de la réforme constitutionnelle
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui est prévu
alors qu'il veut si on parle de chambre
nous chanterons en cela la réforme
envisagée est à mon sens peut-être l'une
des réformes les plus protéiforme qu'on
ait vu sous la vème république c'est à
dire que presque alors pas tous les
champs mais beaucoup de chants
constitutionnel sont envisagées d'abord
y ait un volet territorial avec la
question corse oui avec notamment la
question aussi de donner un petit peu
plus de liberté aux collectivités
territoriales avec donc une capacité
d'expérimentation qui existe déjà mais
qui devrait donc connaître une nouvelle
rupture voilà il ya un volet alors ça je
crois que c'est le volet le plus
intéressant ayant aussi arrêtera à mon
avis parce que c'est celui qui pose
problème c'est le volet procédure
législative on va essayer de réformer
les méthodes d'autonomes l'autre
argument et après un volet qui est le
moins contesté et qui est peut-être
finalement à mon avis le plus attendu
notamment la retrouver dans tous les
anciens projet de réforme
constitutionnelle depuis au moins dix
ans et le volet institutionnel avec
notamment le fait de réformer un petit
peu le conseil économique social et
environnemental
le fait de réformer aussi la cour de
justice de la république ça fait des
années qu'on en parle et je crois que
c'est vraiment une bonne chose et il ya
une dernière c'est le non cumul des
mandats dans le temps c'est dur c'est là
que ça va bloquer au sénat alors deux
choses la première c'est que sur tous
les sujets qu'on a évoqué tous
n'implique pas nécessairement à
proprement parler de la révision de la
conscience suivant on peut passer par la
voie loi organique loi ordinaire
et la deuxième chose c'est la manière
justement de réviser la constitution
puisque là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quel point c'est dur vraiment le
jeune arbitre alors lesquels ne
nécessite pas de réforme de la
constitution par exemple alors par
exemple et c'est très étonnant puisque
ces contrastes beaucoup sur ce terrain
avec la plupart des pays européens par
exemple sur la réforme du mode de
scrutin à la proportionnelle dookie qui
n'implique pas nécessairement de réviser
la constitution
saluant 86 d'ailleurs si tu la nuit
c'est à dire qu'on n'a même pas besoin
du fameux sénat et le scénario aura pas
de l'autre je suis sûr qu'ils
bloqueraient bombay en tout cas ça
tournoi vraiment purement réveillère
donc avec le thème la majorité
parlementaire et s'est fait passer la
réforme du scrutin donc introduire cette
idée s'est introduit à 12,2 propres
ailes après tout dépend de savoir quel
de quelle dose il s'agira sans le savoir
après il ya la limitation donc la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
qui implique un passage par la loi
organique
en fait c'est peut-être plus court de
dire ce qui implique la révision la
constitution c'est sur la révision de la
cour de justice de la république et puis
sur le nouveau statut qui va être
conférés aux à la corse sur le droit à
la différenciation locale qui l'avons
appliqué une révision de la constitution
alors ceci dit et le non cumul
alors non c'est je crois que c'est pas
la mort gagny alors à mon sens il ya
quand même un point constitutionnelle
qui va devoir être discuté c'est la
question du droit d'amendement parce que
c'est vrai qu'on en parle beaucoup ces
derniers temps je sais pas si ça va
vraiment figurer dans le dans le projet
de loi constitutionnelle mais en tout
cas
emmanuel macron a laissé entendre qu'il
allait limiter le droit d'amendement des
parlementaires et là c'est vrai qu'on a
un article 44 de la constitution qui ont
fait un des droits fondamentaux des
parlementaires donc cette question là
sera forcément une question
constitutionnelle
quant à la question du non cumul des
mandats la tradition veut que les
éléments de mots
honda aussi bien parlementaires soient
normalement relégué au rang organique
néanmoins c'est vrai que là on peut se
poser la question de savoir si le non
cumul des mandats dans le temps va
vraiment avoir une importance telle
qu'on aimerait l'inscrire dans la
constitution mais normalement on passe
par la loi organique
attention ça ne veut pas pour autant
dire qu'on va diminuer le rôle du sénat
bien nos contrées et je pense qu'ils
veulent inscrire dans la constitution ce
qui pose un sérieux problème
ce qui pose pas de problème c'est la
réforme de la cour de justice
je crois que c'est vrai tout cela en
gros ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
au lieu d'avoir une cour spéciale pour
les peaux les hommes politiques on va
pour les élus ils passeront par les
instances alors ce qui est prévu je
crois c'est vrai notamment une chambre
particulière à l'instruction auprès
laisse la cour de cassation ouvre et au
moins d'une dinde un tribunal de
première instance notamment pour essayer
quand même de filtrer un petit peu plus
les questions qui pourraient apparaître
un peu farfelu ou un peu politique dans
les affaires pénales mais l'or à part
cette chambre d'instruction un peu
particulière ou lille et politiques
serait tout simplement jugé comme des
particuliers ceux ci n'apparaît pas
particulièrement choquant au vu des
échecs cuisants des dernières affaires
de la cour de justice donc je crois que
c'est cette abscence problème le travail
parlementaire en effet alors là c'est
vrai qu est ce que c est ce que c'est
une réduction du rôle du parlement
on peut penser aussi quand même
clairement c'est à dire que vous est ce
que c'est une amélioration du travail
face m alors les deux c'est à dire en
fait chacun se fait son avis alors
traditionnellement le pouvoir législatif
déjà est conférée au parlement mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
lorsqu'on parle de séparation des
pouvoirs entre le pouvoir législatif et
le pouvoir exécutif veut pas forcément
dire qu'un organe renvoie une fonction
le parlement fait du législatif mais le
gouvernement aussi le gouvernement
intervient dans la procédure législative
il a des armes qu'il peut modifier la
loi il peut déposer des projets de loi
est normalement le vrai pouvoir
législatif c'est celui du vote et celui
du pouvoir d'amendement qui normalement
revient aux parlementaires donc là à
partir du moment où on décide non pas de
revenir sur le vote qui évidemment reste
au parlement mais sur le pouvoir de
modifier au cours de la procédure
législative un texte de loi
on prévoit les conditions d'une
limitation de cette possibilité
d'amendement alors pour une raison qui
pas dans cette deuxième augmentation par
l'exécutif au détriment du licite hâtif
voile et +16 c'est pour aller plus vite
et pour des raisons d'efficacité il ya
un abus qui fait aussi du manque un peu
lol ah c'est à dire un temps médiatique
d'opinion qui est un peu plus court
essai certes certains parlementaires
plus
abusent du droit d'amendement président
de l'arp et la procédure législative des
choses qu'on a déjà été dit l'anglo
missions auxquelles je crois qu'il faut
saluer d'ailleurs un point qu'on oublie
c'est qu'on parle de cette réforme
constitutionnelle comme une engagement
de campagne d'emmanuel macron or en
réalité tout le volet procédure
législative est plutôt issu d'une
initiative un peu isolée de françois de
rugy au départ qui a lancé des
conférences des réflexions au sein des
groupes des commissions qui a fait appel
à des experts etc pour travailler mieux
et ça je crois que c'est vraiment une
question que en france on est obligé de
se poser on a un parlement à s'est
dissipée c'est vrai que notamment les
séances sont un peu rocambolesques et
donc il est important de travailleurs
david important de rationaliser un peu
le travail parlementaire je pense que
c'est une bonne initiative et la plupart
des ddd des propositions qui avait fait
françois de rugy n'ont finalement pas
forcément été reprise dans ce projet de
loi constitutionnelle et à mon avis
peut-être que le fait d'avoir même ne
serait ce cadre c'est le mot droit
d'amendement est une erreur de la part
d' emmanuel macron dans le sens où il y
avait beaucoup d'autres propositions
très intelligent à partir du moment où
là on tape sur le droit d'amendement on
a tendance à crisper dans sa pensée
voilà qu'on va le réduire encore les
parlementaires et c'est déjà une chambre
d'enregistrement n'est pas là dessus que
se posent l'essentiel des problèmes
c'est plutôt le fait qu'il y ait des
multiplications d'amendements ou du
temps de parole complètement abusif mais
ça n'est pas sur le droit d'amendement
par groupe qu'il ya un problème je pense
pas ce soit le nombre d'amendements qui
pose problème c'est plutôt la nature de
ces amendements mais là encore ce n'est
pas sûr ça qu'on travaille donc j'ai
l'impression que la mesure qui est
annoncé mais finalement pas la bonne
pour
améliorer le travail françois de rugy
acquise à klang on veut parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas fauté la réforme
constitutionnelle sous sarkozy est là
c'est grâce à jack lang alors qu'elle
est adoptée
on va rentrer dans une question
politique après c'est alors il ya deux
manières de réformer la constitution
pour l'expliquer ça s'est vite il ya
deux ans alors en fait il ya deux il ya
il ya même trois manières en fait
appropriée donc alors soit on passe par
la voix de l'article 89 de la
constitution soit par la voie l'article
11 de la constitution
si on passe par la voix de l'article 89
de la constitution il faut dans un
premier temps un vote des deux
assemblées législatives
une fois que ce vote est obtenue il ya
deux possibilités qui sont offertes soit
de passer par la voie du référendum soit
de passer par la reine du parlement en
congrès et il ya une autre voie qui est
intéressante parce qu'elle ne décide
nécessite pas forcément que l'accord des
deux chambres donc un premier vote des
deux chambres
c'est en passant par laval l'article 11
de la constitution sur proposition du
premier ministre le présentera public
peut demander aux français de se
prononcer par la voie du référendum sans
que les deux assemblées se prononce faut
rappeler que c'est là c'est la procédure
qui avait utilisé le général de gaulle
ont 72 notamment qu'on avait parlé à
l'époque de forfaiture de plébiscite
aussi parce que c'est vrai qu'il mettait
en plus son mandat en jeu mais savaient
faire débat enfin une polémique énorme
le président moderne qui était président
du sénat enfin c'est cela était il ya
vingt ans on avait l'impression qu'on
avait d'un côté les résidents de la
république et de l'autre ceux dont deux
régimes plus c'est un peu le problème
des référendums voilà que les gens il
veut toujours pas pas pour ou contre le
sujet est pour ou contre la personne qui
propose justement alors est-ce que c'est
ce que c'est un risque politique de même
s'ils auraient une réforme parce que là
visiblement
c'est pas le voit ses effectifs se dit
on à l'opinion derrière nous elle aide
les gens sont pour le pour que le
restant de le cumul des mandats donc ils
vont voter pour b le premier référendum
qu'on a eu les derniers temps c'est que
les gens ne votent jamais pour les vrais
progrès mais la question qui l'a opposée
mais et d'autres installés rose on peut
pas se penser qu'on peut pas penser une
seule seconde que les militants de la
france insoumise les militants du front
national beaucoup les militants
d'extrême gauche sectaire kolo une
partie de la droite votent pour soutenir
avait quelque chose qui serait proposée
par le gouvernement par macron donc
voilà c'est ça sera extrêmement
dangereux c'est dangereux en ce jour ces
nouveautés ou si c'était c'est une rolls
des estimations plus c'est dangereux
aussi pour une autre raison c'est que à
mon sens est venu vaincre on est en
train de friser un petit peu avec les
habits gaullien de la vème république
parce que il a un usage assez musclé
quand même de la procédure législative
il a aidé les auteurs voilà il utilise
beaucoup les ordonnances on le sait que
le parlement des métros il a déterré la
procédure de l'article 44-3 le vote
bloqué pour pour un petit peu museler
les débats donc la question est de
savoir si finalement il ne va pas après
frisé lentilles le labit
antiparlementaire et ça ça peut être
assez dangereux parce que du coup on va
lui donner un petit peu les habits
d'une époque avec ce côté bonapartiste
qu'il aime bien d'ailleurs travaillé
aussi un petit peu
donc le risque c'est du sud justement de
passer pour l' hyperprésident un petit
peu comme line et nicolas sarkozy c'est
pour ça je suis pas sûr que le
référendum soit une bonne solution
rajoutons est-ce que c'est ce que c'est
une menace pour l'instant plus qu'autre
chose je crois que c'est plutôt une
solution de repli parce que c'est vrai
que la procédure normale de révision
faut aussi le rappeler c'est à dire que
l'artisanat n'est pas une position situe
ce court ça colle mais bon parler de
voiture ce n'était pas pareil c'est très
dur et vous avez raison le général de
gaulle à déterrer ce fut encore une tous
les constitutionnalistes disait ce n'est
pas l'approché du corps une fois sur un
tel sujet on imagine le taux
d'abstention là ça va être
oui quelque chose de faramineux aller
quand même
c'est ce qui est encore plus dangereux
c'est que seuls les véritables militants
politiques qui vont vouloir faire de ce
référendum éventuel salut qu'à un acte
politique vont se déplacer mais sinon au
fin fond de la campagne ou des villes
etc
les gens vont vouloir pas de la vision
de la constitution je viens c'est vrai
que depuis 2005 et l'échec du référendum
sur la constitution européenne le 10 mai
nichols avec des risques de surmonter le
parlement parce que justement l'article
89 prévoit que de toute façon il ya une
procédure législative qui est
obligatoire au même terme entre les deux
assemblées et le référendum c'est une
manière de court circuiter ce blocage du
sénat c'est intelligent et à la fois
c'est risqué parce que du coup ça laisse
entendre que la capacité réformatrice d'
emmanuel macron qu'il aime beaucoup
mettre en avant doit se faire sans qu'il
y ait de barrières et le parlement
apparaît donc comme finalement une
barrière et ça c'est un peu dangereux
parce que à mon avis le parlement doit
aussi apparaître comme un allié comme
quelqu'un avec lequel on aime travailler
or là il peut un petit peu passer pour
celui qui aime bien qu'on circuiter
parlement et je crois que c'est pour ça
qu'ils essayent d'éviter la question
pour le moment
à mon sens néanmoins tant qu'ils
travaillent pas un peu au niveau du
sénat il va y être contraint puis on
s'est donné on sait très bien qu'en plus
le peu de cas que font
dernièrement les gouvernements des
résultats au référendum fait j'ai un
référendum sur l'europe la france vote
non bon tu peux c'est pas grave on va
attendre un an puis ça sera oui donc là
c'était quand même enfin à peu près
notre dame des landes fication parce que
l'élève c'est pas la même chose
enfin ce qui a été adopté après des pas
la même chose que ce qui avait été
proposé
en tout cas vous avez vous êtes
peut-être pu même probablement raison
sur le film et lui ce qui est
juridiquement de faire ça mais il ya
sûrement des arguments juridiques mais
l'impression du français qui va voter
non c'est que au bout d'un an on lui dit
faisait voter nos majoritairement mais
finalement ça va être un oui alors oui
certes un peu différent c'est notre dame
des landes
les français votent pour nous mais c'est
pas grave ok vous avez voté j'ai voté
pour l'aéroport mais c'est pas grave on
le fait pas voilà allez allez réveiller
les gens en disant que maintenant d'un
troisième référendum ça va être amusant
celle ci fait beau et que l'on peut
aller pêcher je pense que non mais parce
que finalement on parle de référendum
vraiment de risques mais bon on a un
discours très protecteur de la
démocratie représentative mais c'est
bien si la démocratie directe
c'est bien que les sources dire que ce
n'était pas grave si finalement il est
petit répondre aux passionnés
et les référendums si on a quand même
toujours cet historique de de gaulle
c'est dire qu'il mettait son mandat en
jeu mais je te dise si vous mettez non
je m'en vais et il l'a fait en 69
mais on pourrait avoir une vision plus
comment disait giscard des passionnés
enfin moi je suis pour la passion et moi
et je trouvais justement qu'il y avait
dans l'attitude du général de gaulle un
courage énorme qui consistait justement
donc à remettre en cause son mandat si
les français lui disait le général de
gaulle avait cette idée c'est que à de
très grandes responsabilités qui sont
celles du président la république impose
une petite une très grande légitimité et
le général de gaulle n'attendez pas
l'intervalle de deux élections
présidentielles se re légitimer et c'est
bien le problème c'est à dire que quand
on a un président la république qui se
prend une claque au référendum
rires ah mais complètement mais s'impose
donc la fonction et on affaiblit
complètement dans le présent la
république est très petit mais qui a
trop de pouvoir donc moi je trouve que
s'ils survivent et se conserver cette
posture présidentielle qui la garde
jusqu'au bout et qu'ils soient de gauche
jusqu'au bout et qu'il mettre en jeu
saint josse et au menton messi avait
deux référendums parents par exemple ça
serait beaucoup plus des passionnés et
parce qu'on en veut te disent très peu
c'est d'ailleurs ce référendum à mon
avis est un peu un manque à bhl temps
qu'on n'arrive pas à amadouer un petit
peu le sénat lui s'oppose comme ça le
sera le sénat est à droite
il faut le rappeler c'est à dire que
c'est le seul organe politique pour le
moment qui n'est pas dans la majorité a
lancé m sur 2 2 il ya déjà un petit peu
cela il faut savoir aussi que le sénat
est conservateur et le non cumul des
mandats
just jack lang qui disait mais oui quand
même le non cumul des mandats pour enfin
de trois ans et on aurait vite et
montceau n'aurait pas fait de carrière
politique mitterrand bien sûr je suis
pas sûr que ce soit dans là alors c'est
dans l'air du temps mais je suis pas sûr
que ce soit forcément une bonne mesure
notamment on avait beaucoup d'américains
qui ont regretté le fait que barack
obama ait pas pu se représenter parce
qu'il avait brigué de mandat
est-ce que c'est intéressant quand on a
quelqu'un de bien
le briguer de le bris mais tout
simplement parce qu'il est resté parce
que c'est bien que les gens restent au
pouvoir
alors après c'est la question du
vieillissement de senna qui qui qui est
toujours un petit 6 hambourg voilà vous
êtes très gaullien cherchent non je suis
très de démocratie directe c'est-à-dire
que les électeurs trancheront le logo
alors est-ce que la sphère à johnny vous
passionne comme le passé parce que c'est
vrai que y'a pas n'ya pas dîner où les
gens se ne se déchirent pas il ya les
pros laetitia les protège et elora non
qu'est ce qui nous passionne dans cette
affaire j'ai l'impression qu'on a une
sorte de famille royale comme ça délire
on les appelle par leur prénom david
laura je crois que ce qui fascine un
petit peu c'est la différence d'âge qui
avait faim qu'il ya entre laëtitia est
géniale idée les plus proches de
laëtitia est plus proche de l'aura
qu'elle ne l'était de son mari donc les
ja il ya un côté le projet on a fait un
match mais du coup ça peut développer un
peu une idée de nous non pas d'une veuve
noire mais mes outils bas voilà est-ce
que ce que laetitia n'était pas là
maintenant avec en plus cet entourage
quelqu'un qui a l'air un peu trouble
quand même
on dirait un presque un mauvais polar
enfin la mamy rock qui l'entourent le
frère de
on a vraiment l'impression quand même
réussi de tant de questions que c'est
que yann johnny étant une telle icône un
tel mythe
donc il ne peut pas avoir fait des
choses qui sont bâle et pour les
français déshérités des enfants c'est
pas très beau qu'il était forcément
manipuler moi je crois que ce qui
passionne les français dans cette
question alors non seulement le statut
iconique vous l'avez dit de de johnny
c'est aussi le c'est une affaire
familiale et c'est vrai que dès qu'on
touche à la famille en france on a
affaire à quelque chose d'assez
passionné il faut savoir aussi que on
est dans un droit français qui est dans
une habitude française qui me semble
être un petit peu triste qui consiste à
trancher les affaires de coupe les
affaires financières patrimoniale et de
famille une fois le défunt défunt or
c'est un peu dommage à mon sens parce
qu'il ya des choses qui peut souvent des
problèmes mais peut-être qu'on pourrait
essayer de faire des choses du vivant de
la personne et je crois que ce qu'il ya
des traitements violents dans dans ce
pays parce que la cellule de la volonté
voilà c'est la surprise et pourquoi ne
pas en avoir parlé en amont c'était une
des belles initiatives à mon avis de
nicolas sarkozy d'avoir voulu essayer de
moderniser un petit peu les donation
entre vifs
est-ce que c'est pas un peu dommage dans
les familles et aussi bien dans une
famille qu'on aime autant que la famille
à l'idée parce qu'on les connaît tous
est-ce que c'est pas dommage de ne pas
avoir parlé de cela avant et 7 700 un
peu qui interloque à mon sens les
français c'est que on se rend compte
après le décès de l'idole que finalement
des choses obscures n'ont pas été réglés
à temps et c'est un peu ça le danger
c'est un peu ça le danger de notre
législation aussi et nos habitudes c'est
que on se préoccupe de sa au décès et
que ça donne toujours lieu à des
affaires sicilienne quoi donc c'est
c'est une habitude française aussi de
ceux de ceux de s'écharper on va dire
autour des testaments
c'est dommage et on en a ici une
illustration des plus tristes à mon sens
jeudi après la loi française en principe
les villes de s'écharper puisque
on ne peut pas déshériter saison donc
c'est assez clair l'achat il y aura une
bagarre entre la loi de l'américain
alors pour tous les français mais après
il une statue ses rites et ses enfants
tu as raison il ya cette réserve
héréditaire mais il ya plein de
possibilités d'y déroger également un
c'est à dire qu'il ya la possibilité de
faire un testament qui certes doit
toujours respecter - cette réserve est
là mais notamment lorsqu'on à l'eau
seront disponibles ce soir voilà quand
on a le conjoint plus jeunes il y a la
possibilité de déroger par convention en
laissant notamment du fruit ou en
empêchant en jeu l'an un petit peu là le
partage le temps que l'époux zde c'est
d'elle même donc il ya de toute façon
déjà un sentiment d'injustice qui peut
se dégager de ce type de conflit c'est
ça qui est un peu dangereux c'est que on
a affaire à la famille on a affaire à
des choses qui n'ont pas été tranchées
pendant le vivant de la personne donc on
lui prête une volonté et on est donc
fondé ce rocher en tout cas de son
enfant n'arrive pas à savoir en tout cas
si cette volonté de johnny était une
volonté qui avait été tranchée en
famille si david et laura était au
courant qu'il n'aurait rien si
l'éthicien avait acquis ce rôle de
gardienne du patrimoine même musicale du
chanteur
est-ce que c'était su est ce que tout le
monde le savait et est-ce que donc il
joue la comédie ici ou est ce qu'il ya
vraiment cet écrit surprise moi j'ai le
sentiment que c'est l'effet de surprise
qui fait que les aînés sont en train de
vouloir contester quelque chose parce
que ils ont le sentiment que ça ne peut
pas correspondre à la volonté de leur
père et en plus sa cause il ya quand
même une tendance française qui est
quand même très favorables les rita
c'est vrai on ne déshérite pas ses
enfants
notamment ses enfants ci n'est pas dû à
une tradition des anneaux n'est qu'alors
que la mode et c'est à dire voilà tout
de même tous les milliardaires pour des
fondations x1 aux états unis on peut
tout donner à son âme stay donc non mais
c'est vrai que et c'est peut-être
tendance qui parce que je sais pas si
une peut-être qu'il me semble que
l'opinion française est plutôt favorable
aux david et et laura enfin parce
qu'elle je pense qu'à sayat c'est ce
côté comment est on peut pas déshériter
ses enfants et ce que je répète en plus
ça peut pas être lui donner du mal à
imaginer que ça viendrait après cette
idée là mais c'est ça que je trouve qui
est assez inquiétant même si je
comprends que ça suscite un fantasme
mais c'est qu'on a que des six parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'a dit johnny on
sait ce qu en disent donc le versailles
étape oui enfin récemment produit en vie
alors on peut raisonner un juriste et ne
prendre que les éléments juridiques mais
enfin c'est qu'après il ya une réalité
j'imagine que ils se parlent ils se
disent des choses et que apparemment
donc les enfants étaient surpris la
décision et de ce testament donc
indépendamment de moi je ne reste pas
sur le terrain juridique
on peut du rythme et du droit c'est sûr
surtout que finalement on ne sait pas
tout et qu'il est à mon avis difficile
pour un français qui ne connaît pas
toutes ces affaires de se prononcer en
disant je suis plutôt favorable à l'un
ou à l'autre moi je moi j'ai une espèce
de 2
je suis mal à l'aise par rapport à ça
d'autant qu'en plus finalement on se
projette beaucoup dans cette histoire
parce qu' énormément de familles sont
concernées par cette situation même si
c'est pas forcément de trois wilayas et
de 2500 chansons avec des droits
d'auteur mais
je pense que les français s'intéressent
à ça parce que finalement ça les
concerne aussi c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît je rajouterais que je trouve que
là c'est en train de prendre une
tournure un peu différente est un peu
dérangeante à mon sens c'est que il
commence à y avoir des pros l'un et des
prolos et notamment dans leur soutien
dans les gens qui ont été présents à
l'enterrement
et il ya un acharnement sur laëtitia qui
donne un petit peu le sentiment que
c'est finalement la personne qui
profitent du crime un petit peu comme tu
le décrivait dans un mauvais polar et
voilà gardons la prudence de savoir
qu'il ya une volonté du défunt il
faudrait essayer des marques
qu'est ce qu'il en est il est l'idée
d'après des proches
l'idée qui ont manipulé jody surtout en
plus ça a l'air d'être une volonté
assumée il ya d'abord eu un exil qui
s'ensuivent à la bourre après il ya des
témoignages qui le protège personne
voilà donc dit rien on ne sait rien
c'est pas s'il a été manipulée ou s'ils
étaient manipulés quel dommage d'une
table s'est forgée à l'amiable a
finalement on ne sait pas alors un autre
chanteur guillaume durand moins de
soucis pour son héritage un mur de huy
c'est bertrand cantat
bertrand cantat qui était condamné pour
la mort de marie trintignant eux
et voilà donc il leur fait des concerts
les des concerts donnent lieu à des
impôts de violence il ya des crachats et
des manifestations en tous cas au vent
il ya le partage c'est entre ceux qui
disent voilà il
il a été condamné il a fait sa peine il
a payé sa dette à la société qu'on vous
dis donc il faut galles qui il faut bien
le réinsérer
et puis ceux qui disent banon il devrait
comme dit olivier marchal devrait fermer
sa gueule de quel côté parce que c'est
pas des pas si facile que ça maintenant
même si le crime est odieux même si
voilà non non le crime et bien
évidemment aux dieux après effectivement
été jugé il a fait il a accompli la
peine à laquelle il avait été condamné
donc là dessus ça c'est imparable et
puis tout le monde
un voleur de mobylette comme un assassin
a droit à une certaine rédemption
sinon fallait le condamné à 50 ans de
prison jean ça mais il a été condamné à
huit ans il n'en fait 4 c'est la loi la
pad arnaque donc tout à fait normal
qu'ils puissent chanter ça c'est d'un
point de vue je vais dire logique après
il est vrai que c'est un peu compliqué
de se dire est ce qu'on va aller
applaudir un type qui a assassiné sa
femme
bon moi franchement j'avais pas le voir
avant qu'il assassiné sa femme donc ça
me pose pas de problème j'irai pas le
voir après donc voyez le pervers soit
probable c'est déjà un truc
après on peut comprendre que des gens
que ça choque effectivement mais moi je
reconnais être allé voir des films de
polanski en sachant qu très bien qu'il
avait violé une fille de 15 ans on va
nommer ceux qui jugeaient attention à
nos noms là
on sait bien il les rues drogués je veux
dire n'a pas déjà le nom mais pas très
souvent voire faux dialogue mais oui on
va très souvent voir des harmonies
céline sait pas tout je sais pas j'ai
java sentiment alors on a on a dit sur
la sphère johnny que finalement il y
avait plus de passion que de droit ici
on parle beaucoup de droits est ainsi
peu de morale à mon sens il à dire
qu'elle est deux fois la plaine a été
jugé cet huissier le droit voilà le
droit à l'insertion encore une fois le
droit à la réinsertion est un droit il
ya la morale qui a une place à jouer ici
c'est à dire que quand on est un ancien
criminel est ce que il est légitime
qu'on ait demain envie de refaire
l'olympia alors il le dit je suis
chanteur si j'avais été jardinier je
serais retourné jardinier bon
malheureusement pour moi je suis obligé
de chanter pour vivre on pourrait aussi
imaginer qui peut chanter sous la douche
et puis qu'il peut écrire des textes
pour d'autres sans que ça nous pousse
trop de preuves ne se séparaient s'il
écrivait des textes on dirait malheur
vous avez appelé à dire quelqu'un
alors je sais quand tu as écrit mais la
vraie du secours mais jusqu'où lui at il
des scrupules à se présenter
publiquement il a fait la une des
inrocks est ce que est ce que c'est une
manière de alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
quand même beaucoup de monde a dit les
inrocks c'est pas lui mais c'est vrai
que c'est en tout cas je crois que c'est
vraiment sur une erreur je crois que
c'est vraiment son erreur parce que
c'est ça qui a beaucoup choqué aussi
c'est à dire qu'on a eu le sentiment
qu'il avait envie d'un retour en force
en quelque sorte et après quand il parle
de droit à la réinsertion j'ai envie de
dire c'est aussi un petit peu à double
vitesse c'est à dire que demain si vous
expliquer un jardinier qui justement a
été incarcérés pour un crime que demain
il peut ré ouvrir sa petite boîte et que
tout le monde va retourner chez ce
jardinier là on sait très bien que non
en réalité dans une petite ville il est
fini 1 donc c'est aussi parce que c'est
bertrand cantat qui peut leur revenir
aussi facilement dans son ancien emploi
entre nous et que à mon avis la
réinsertion ne joue pas forcément pour
tout le monde aussi facilement
quand il y avait justement moralement
l'impact que laisse un crime donc c'est
cela vivaces à la question bel exemple
de philip morris quittant le dernier
condamné à mort oui qui a été gracié
puisque c'est arrivé au moment de
l'élection de mitterrand est devenu
universitaire et non mais dans les
exemples récents il faut aussi marie
il faut aussi parler de nabila alors
c'est vrai que bon je trouve que ça fait
ça fait mal quand on en avait pas parlé
donc c'est bien d'en parler mais nabila
elle a quand même été plus ou moins
et encore moins malheureusement à mon
avis trop peu inculpé pour avoir essayé
de garder rejoint même et elle est
encore sur le devant de la scène à
donner des conseils de mode et de
maquillage donc apparemment ce n'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui nous choque
toujours en tout cas voilà il faudrait
arriver à choisir qu est vrai comme
c'était oui en gros la gauche est plutôt
pour l'insertion et quand tu es plutôt
chanteur ne bouge il ya un truc un peu
qui skie ce qui rend le ghetto surcroît
ce qui rend le débat encore plus
compliqué c'est que au delà du crime
il s'agit d'un certain crime oui c'est
ça qui rend les choses encore plus par
deux tous les cinq dernières bon on n'a
pas un violeur ou un type qui qui qui
qui s'est vengé qui après midi thé c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait peut-être dix
minutes avant le meurtre
et même encore dix minutes après cette
dame qui vont malgré tout est décédé
sous les coups de son mari et du coup
très violent et de façon très très très
violente
il a contacté le frère et ses parents
comme une histoire donc c'est ça aussi
qui rend la chose assez particulière
c'est à dire qu'on a quand même
quelqu'un qui a commis un crime et d'une
nature particulière et qui explique
justement qui n'aiment pas fait autant
de prison donc c'est ça aussi qui
rendent débat très compliqué et ce sans
doute insupportable aussi pour eux il
est bien évidemment voilà c'est ce qui
est très important c'est la famille de
la victime presque fini il aurait
assassiné une jeune femme inconnue du
grand public
je dis pas que tout le monde s'en serait
foutu mais ce serait ça serait beaucoup
moins
non mais mal passer dans l'opinion
publique alors que là à chaque fois en
rappel
ah oui c'est quand même marie
trintignant et on voit les parents et on
les comprend tout à fait les enfants
sont curieux supporté voilà pourtant que
la personne l état même 20 pour les
pains de de la victime joue énormément
après c'est quand même gênant dans tout
ça c'est vous disiez c'est ce fesses de
retour à la morale faire que là en ce
moment on sent que tout est maintenant
c'est un point de vue de la morale
les féministes interdisent ceux ci
interdisent cela on peut plus c'est très
grave ce retour à la morale avec bientôt
ne plus pouvoir rien dire sans rien
faire
ainsi si la morale oui et non parce que
enfin ça dépend des sujets je
terminerais juste pour dire que
justement on a parlé du crime qui est le
sien on pourrait dire que c'est un peu
un crime passionnel en tout cas c'est
comme ça que pénalement ça a dû être
vendu pour qu'ils écopent dossier
c'est souvent ça qui laisse beaucoup de
rancoeur c'est que justement ça n'est
pas une peine criminelle de 30 ans de
réclusion mais au contraire souvent sur
des peines un petit peu allégés et du
coup la famille de la victime a très
souvent encore un peu de rancoeur et je
crois que justement c'est à cause de
cette nature-là et de cette pénalisation
là qu'on en est là à ceci près que c'est
un poil plus compliqué parce que lui il
est il était apparemment violent avec
d'autres gens sur ces merci infiniment
mais nos services et jean charles
et à bientôt pour un nouveau pas
[Musique]